for a guy whose job description is
literally crime fighter Batman sure does
spend an awful lot of time fighting
other heroes you'd think having an
entire Asylum full of homicidal clowns
living refrigerators and the occasional
immortal bio terrorists would keep him
busy enough but no every now and then
some well-meaning do-gooder gets in his
way and it's on Batman has a pretty
strong track record against his fellow
heroes here are just a few who have felt
the wrath of the bat Superman
historically speaking Batman and
Superman have been best friends and the
world's finest crime-fighting team since
they met in the mid 40s they share a
mutual desire to devote their lives to
helping others but like all friends they
occasionally have their disagreements
we're willing to bet that most arguments
between Powell's don't usually devolve
into one person using a radioactive
space rock to poison the other but these
guys are really seem like the common
reasonable types the two heroes most
famously came to blows at the climax of
The Dark Knight Returns in which an
aging post-retirement Batman enlists the
help of Green Arrow Robin and the
entirety of Gotham City's power grid to
have a fist fight so brutal that he
ended up giving himself a heart attack
their arguments are limited to
non-canonical alternate futures either
take a look at hush which is essentially
Batman's greatest hits wrapped around
one of comics most ludicrously
convoluted mysteries we see Superman's
mind taken over by poison ivy
which leads Batman to put on a
kryptonite ring and uppercut Superman
back into his right mind it's worth
noting that both of those fights
involved Superman holding back but hey a
victory with an asterisk is still a
victory Green Lantern then we have the
highly controversial all-star Batman and
Robin the Boy Wonder
it's so controversial that you're
probably familiar with it even if you
don't read comics Batman cutting a Dick
Grayson in the Batmobile Wonder Woman
calling a random pedestrian a sperm bank
Batman and black Canary getting turned
on by ultraviolence it all happened in
this one story and you can trust us
context doesn't really make it better
Batman scene with Green Lantern however
is one of those rare moments where
something is so ridiculous but it loops
back around to be
amazing in order to face how Jordan
whose green London ring can't affect
anything yellow Batman lured him into a
room where he has painted literally
everything yellow the furniture his
costume he's even spray-painted his own
face and to top it all off he even
taunts and sneers at green London while
sipping on a refreshing glass of
lemonade until he finally baits him into
a physical confrontation
now of course it's actually Robin who
does the fighting but considering that
Batman's the one who orchestrated the
entire situation
so that a grown-ass superhero could get
his throat crushed by a ten-year-old
slathered in spray-paint it's fair to
say the wind belongs to him Guy Gardner
Batman's Lantern problems are nothing
new coming at you from 1987's Justice
League number five
Batman landed the single most famous
hero vs. hero punch in the history of
the DC Universe and possibly all of
comic history on one side you have guy
Gardner the bowl-cut Green Lantern
commonly known as the biggest jerk in
the DC Universe constantly running his
mouth about how he should be running the
team on the other side we have Batman at
this point you probably know what
happens next the conflict builds for a
few issues until finally diarrhea's back
to take a swing and Batman drops him
with a single punch directly to the nose
knocking your mouth cold guy has hit so
hard that the punch crossed realities
into the Brave and the bold animated
series you so much as sneeze without my
permission you're going to regret dad
I'd like that face one punch took one
punch and the best part guy remains
unconscious on the floor of the Justice
League's kitchen until halfway through
the next issue while the rest of the
team goes on a mission then knocks
himself back out by hitting his head on
the underside of a counter as soon as he
wakes up in other words Batman punched
him so hard and knocked him out twice
Wildcat it's a tale as old as time
boxing champ Ted grant was inspired by a
Green Lantern comic book and decided to
dress up as a 6-foot kitty cat and punch
criminals until crime wasn't a thing
anymore
listen it was 1941 nobody really knew
what they were doing back then
Wildcat has traditionally been shown as
one of the fighters that trained Bruce
Wayne in the art of combat during his
teenage years button Bravin the bold the
joke
was able to force them to fight each
other how by threatening to shoot a
puppy ultimately they knocked each other
out at the same time listen it was 1975
they definitely knew what they were
doing but that doesn't mean it didn't
get weird with it and if it's good
enough for National Lampoon it's good
enough for the Joker Punisher while
they're both on the same side in the
broadest way possible the Punishers
tendency to leave his opponents of
bullet-riddled corpses clashes with
Batman's time-tested code against
killing and that comes to a head when
Batman stops The Punisher from killing
the Joker during Punisher / Batman a
deadly night before Batman can explain
that this is probably why the Punisher
doesn't have a lot of recurring villains
Frank Castle decks him with a hard right
and Batman in classic fashion tells him
he let him have one punch because he
knows he's frustrated when Punisher
takes a second swing however Batman
doesn't just catch his fist he casually
throws him face-first into a wall with a
blunt I said 1 Captain America
Batman vs. Captain America is one of the
most perfect matchups you could ask for
the only problem is settling on a winner
and while the odds would tend to favor
the super soldier over the world's
greatest detective that's not always how
it works out in 1996 his DC vs. Marvel
the decision was left up to a vote by
the fans the result was a brawl that
took place in a sewer in which the
heroes fought each other to a standstill
until a sudden rush of water swamped
captain gave Berman the chance to pop
him over the head with a Batarang it's
not exactly the most dignified ending to
a fight but hey a victory with a
technicality is still a victory
interestingly enough when the two
characters squared off again for 2003
JLA / Avengers
Batman conceded that while Captain
America could be to Ministry to fight
nobody had time for author ain't nobody
got time for that which when you think
about it it's a pretty great way to
weasel your way out of a rematch Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles the weirdest thing
about the Batman / Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles crossover is that it somehow
didn't happen in 1990 it wasn't until
2015 that they actually met up but when
they did it was pretty much everything
you wanted to see the men
in hopping adventure shredder pitted
against Ra's al Ghul and Mr Freeze
transformed into a mutant polar bear
which is pretty amazing and of course it
also gives you a hero versus hero fight
just to start things off and unlike most
of these this one actually makes a lot
of sense if you're Batman and you see a
bunch of five-foot turtles of ninja
weapons running around town
everything that's happened over the past
75 years it's going to lead you to the
conclusion that they're probably up to
no good Batman not only takes out each
of the four Ninja Turtles in turn and
the fight splinter to a draw before the
turtles after retreats he also takes
their weapons and uses Raphael Sai to
shatter Leonardo's katana in the end the
turtles pretty much become Batman's
biggest fans give me the camera
look doing his Batman or Hulk it's the
most improbable victory of all time and
it happened in 1981 Batman versus The
Incredible Hulk for the most part it's a
pretty fantastic fight putting Batman on
the defensive against hopes and
stoppable physical force it even
includes awesome moments like a Batman
busting out a Jackie Chan style dodge by
leaping straight through the open
windows of a Hulk old car as it smashes
against the wall the end of their first
encounter though has one of the biggest
bits of belief stretching since Captain
America was swamped by sewer water after
realizing that punching isn't going to
get anywhere Batman simply drops some
knockout gas and then delivers a kick to
the solar plexus so hard that the Hulk
is forced to take a deep inhale of that
sweet sleepy cloud Hulk hits the floor
and Batman celebrates a victory des
probably never should have happened
[Music]
thanks for watching click the loop icon
to subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love to
[Music]